let's talk about the Affordable Care Act
also known as Obamacare and what it
means for you so you've got private
health insurance already maybe you have
it your job or your parents Obamacare
means you get a host of new benefits and
protections for example insurance
companies are now required to cover
women's wellness visits mammograms birth
control for women immunizations for kids
all without charging you a penny more
that means no extra co-pays or fees
young adults can now stay on their
parents plan until they turn 26
insurance companies can't limit the
amount of care they'll cover over your
lifetime also if your insurance company
spends more than twenty percent of your
premium dollars on overhead stuff like
CEO salaries marketing administrative
costs they have to send you a refund for
the difference in January that list of
benefits gets even longer it will be
illegal to charge you higher premiums or
refuse coverage because you get sick or
have been in the past charging women
more than men for the exact same
coverage also illegal no more
deciphering page after page of jargony
paperwork from your insurance company to
determine what they will or won't cover
instead you'll get a short plain
language summary of your benefits and
coverage easy right you can learn more
at healthcare.gov okay what about the
folks without health insurance or people
who buy coverage on their own here's
what Obamacare has for you a new simple
way to buy affordable high quality
health insurance starting october first
you can go to healthcare.gov and use the
new health insurance marketplace to see
all of the health plans available in
your area and sign up for the one that
fits your needs and your budget you can
also find out if you're eligible to pay
less for private health insurance or
whether you qualify for other free or
low-cost programs all the plans in the
marketplace are required to cover a core
set of essential health benefits
doctor's visits emergency care
prescriptions and lab tests we have for
illness or injury mental health services
they all come standard plus all those
benefits and protections available to
people who already have insurance no
cost preventive care coverage for
pre-existing conditions accountability
for insurance companies you get all of
that to you can apply for marketplace
coverage
four ways online at healthcare.gov by
mail on the phone or in person and open
enrollment starts October first you can
learn more right now by visiting
healthcare gov or calling 1-800 318 to
596 so here's the bottom line whether
you need help coverage or you have it
already the Affordable Care Act offers
new rights and protections that make
coverage fairer and easier to understand